[Musica]
adoro a fotografare in fotografia ogni
lente restituisce una realtà diversa
ognuno di noi ha la propria lente
culturale esperienziale emotiva che ci
permette di vedere eventi oggetti idee
in maniera diversa e ci fa immaginare
scenari futuri
purtroppo l'abitudine di guardare
l'ambiente in cui viviamo sempre dalla
stessa prospettiva
fa sì che la maggior parte delle persone
pensi che esista un unico paradigma
possibile ma quando si esce dal si è
sempre fatto così accade qualcosa di
straordinario e di dirompente
amo raccontare la storia di bruno
vaschetti un appassionato ornitologo che
negli anni ottanta decise di trasformare
la sua azienda familiare una cascina di
racconigi un tempo di proprietà di
savoia in un'oasi naturalistica
in questa zona agricola a sud di torino
lui ebbe l'intuizione di reintrodurre la
cicogna bianca estinta in italia nel
1700 e creò il primo centro cicogne
d'italia
negli anni questo luogo è diventato
l'habitat ideale per moltissime forme di
vita
che hanno trovato cura e rifugio e sono
stati portati avanti numerosi progetti
di educazione ambientale e di tutela dei
territori
l'esempio di bruno e della sua splendida
famiglia in persona per me
l'incrollabile fiducia e la perseveranza
di chi vuole migliorare l'ambiente che
ci circonda
è l'esempio di come l'azione dell'uomo
si è ispirato da principi di comunione e
di appartenenza all'ambiente in cui vive
può produrre risultati di enorme valore
etico
immaginare il nostro futuro è stato il
mio lavoro per quasi vent'anni a
supporto delle pubbliche amministrazioni
nelle politiche ambientali di sviluppo
locale dei territori
le scienze naturali con il pensiero
sistemico mi hanno insegnato che la
bellezza della natura dipende dagli
occhi con cui la guardiamo ed alla cura
che li riserviamo
per le città
accadde la stessa cosa
ho anche imparato che l'innovazione
risiede nelle intersezioni
ed è proprio lì che nascono le nuove
idee
e quindi ho pensato
e se le nostre nelle nostre città
avessimo come priorità quello di vivere
mangiare spostarsi in maniera
sostenibile e se le politiche urbane si
concentrassero nel creare spazi pubblici
condivisi in cui connetterci come
comunità
e se tirassimo città a misura di bambini
è possibile
le città gentili è un manifesto
d'intenti
una collezione di valori fondanti
attraverso la mia mente la gentilezza è
lo strumento con cui diventare veri
agenti di cambiamento
se vogliamo
una città più resiliente
dobbiamo iniziare a chi a farci una
domanda fondamentale
a chi appartengono le nostre strade
mediamente il 40 per cento degli
spostamenti giornalieri in città avviene
al di sotto dei 5 km
eppure l'italia è il paese europeo con
il maggior numero di auto per abitanti
la nostra dipendenza dalle auto
sta minando la nostra salute e quella
dell'ambiente
spazi pubblici condivisi sono molto
importanti provate a immaginare la città
dal punto di vista di un bambino
in una città a misura di auto i bambini
devono rinunciare a moltissime cose
aria pulita silenzio indipendenza andare
a scuola in sicurezza a giocare a
esplorare gli automobilisti invece non
rinunciano a nulla anzi
occupano la maggior parte dello spazio
pubblico
solo sfidando il diritto acquisito di
parcheggiare ovunque
davanti a un edificio
le città hanno la possibilità di salvare
generazioni di bambini
altrimenti abituati a non uscire
incontrarsi giocare
il cambiamento radicale delle nostre
città
richiedono pensieri radicali
e pensieri radicali richiedono nuovi
immaginari
con il potere dell'immaginazione città
come new york los angeles denver
hanno aderito a un progetto di
rigenerazione urbana molto ambizioso il
one million tris con lo scopo di
piantare un milione di alberi nelle loro
città i benefici sono enormi ma vorrei
soffermarmi sull'enorme impatto che
rigenera la città con la natura sulla
nostra salute mentale e fisica
secondo il world economic forum
la vicinanza della natura ci aiuta ad
abbassare l'ormone dello stress a
ridurre il nostro battito cardiaco a
rafforzare il nostro sistema immunitario
anche il senso di solitudine viene meno
basterebbero 120 minuti alla settimana
nella natura per essere più felici e più
creativi
ecco immaginate che cosa accadrebbe se
veramente agissimo sulla base di queste
informazioni
se ad esempio ognuno di noi avesse un
area verde a meno di 300 metri da casa
non sarebbe meraviglioso
ma
trasformare gli spazi delle nostre città
da soli non basta dobbiamo anche
ripensare le nostre abitudini alle
nostre azioni quotidiane
una delle più grandi sfide che la città
si ritrova ad affrontare oggi è la
riduzione dell'impronta ecologica che
dipende dei beni che acquistiamo dei
materiali con cui costruiamo dal cibo
che mangiamo
ci sono città ambiziose che già stanno
lavorando sul creare un sistema
alimentare locale nel rispetto degli al
delle altre persone del pianeta e degli
animali
anni fa visita in una cittadina belga
ghent e rimasi molto colpita dalla
campagna dei vecchi dei letteralmente e
giovedì il giorno delle verdure in cui
una volta la settimana
i ristoranti servono a dei piatti a base
vegetale al posto della carne
sull'esempio di londra un'associazione
no profit portò questo progetto a ghent
in questi anni
questo progetto ha contribuito al
miglioramento e al cambiamento delle
abitudini alimentari di molte persone
nel 2013 un terzo degli abitanti aderito
giovedì mag
dopo soli tre anni consumo di carne e
diluito notevolmente il 25 per cento di
loro mangia carne una volta alla
settimana e il 20 per cento di loro
mangia la carne e due volte al mese
molti ristoranti hanno aderito
all'iniziativa e la città si è impegnata
nell introdurre una dieta vegetale anche
nelle scuole e negli hotel
un approccio gentile alla città
significa attivarsi non rimanere passivi
un'azione per quanto apparentemente
semplice può avere un impatto
incredibile
ed è quello che ho sperimentato
all'inizio della pandemia nella
primavera del 2020 qui a torino la mia
città le case del quartiere hanno
aiutato persone e famiglie in difficoltà
attraverso la distribuzione di cibo e di
beni di prima necessità
spontaneamente molti volontari negozi
mercati rionali ditte hanno messo a
disposizione i loro beni e il loro tempo
in un momento così drammatico come
quello che abbiamo dovuto vivere tutti
noi ho avuto modo di vedere come le
persone avessero scelto di scambiarsi
cura e attenzione
e di come esista un ponte invisibile a
unire le persone anche su acque citate
e soprattutto mi ha fatto pensare che se
vogliamo una città più bella più gentile
più giusta le nostre azioni non
dovrebbero essere più belle più gentili
più giuste
esser ottimisti e faticoso
richiede disciplina
forza interiore
perseveranza
esser ottimisti riguardo l'ambiente
significa voler proteggere in una
società abituata a distruggere
significa attivarsi metterci la faccia
siamo tutti interconnessi e abbiamo una
precisa responsabilità collettiva
le città gentili sono la dimostrazione
che se noi come individui riconosciamo
questa interdipendenza e questa
interconnessione
possiamo accelerare di molto i nostri
sforzi per un futuro migliore
perché impatto e trasformazione possono
essere raggiunti solo combinando
replicando tutte quelle iniziative che
mirano al bene comune
le nostre città meritano di essere amate
accudite
celebrate e per fare questo è necessario
iniziare a guardarle con occhi nuovi
e quindi dovremmo chiederci attraverso
quale l'ente guarderemo alla nostra
città da oggi in poi grazie
[Applauso]